muy bien digamos que tenemos una función
que solamente tiene una entrada y esa
entrada le llamamos t muy bien y además
tiene una salida que es un vector y este
vector va a depender de t así que
digamos que nuestra componente en x
estévez es el coseno de t y que nuestra
componente yesera t veces el seno de t y
esto es a lo que llamamos una función
paramétrica y quizás debería ser más
preciso lo que estoy diciendo esto
debería llamarse una función paramétrica
de un parámetro
parámetro verdad y parámetro es
simplemente una palabra elegante para
decir entrada ok así que en este caso t
es nuestro único parámetro lo cual hace
que ésta sea una función paramétrica
verdad y lo que pensamos es digamos en
dibujar la curva ya que su salida es
multidimensional entonces uno podría
decir bueno vamos a visualizar esto
verdad tenemos una entrada tenemos una
salida de dos dimensiones al graficar lo
podríamos poner tres puntos tres números
juntos y graficar los pero resulta ser
mejor simplemente fijarnos en el espacio
de salidas así que nuestro espacio de
salidas es de dos dimensiones
vamos a continuar dibujando nuestro
plano coordenada aquí y simplemente
vamos a estar evaluando esta función a
distintos puntos y veremos qué es lo que
lo que resulta en este caso así que
quizás digamos el punto más fácil para
evaluarlo sería cuando te vale cero así
que
efe de cero sería simplemente será cero
en ambas coordenadas verdad tendremos
cero por otra cosa cero por el coseno de
cero será cero
y 0 veces el seno de 0 también será 0
así que nuestra entrada 0 corresponde a
la salida que es el vector 0 0 verdad y
podríamos pensar que este vector es un
es infinitamente pequeño o que
simplemente es un punto en el origen
verdad sin embargo cuando cuando tomamos
otro punto distinto digamos podríamos
tomar y medios por supuesto la razón por
la cual el sumado pi medios de entre
todos los números es porque sabemos
calcular seno de pi medios y coseno depp
y medios así que ya debería estar
pensando cuánto valen esto es verdad y
quizás la forma digamos que podríamos
utilizar para recordar cuánto vale el
coseno de pi medios y el seno de pi
medios sería dibujando un círculo
unitario verdad entonces vamos a poner
un círculo unitario de este lado verdad
y recordemos que el coseno depp y medio
sería la digamos la coordenada x de
cuando tomamos un ángulo de pi medio es
verdad y eso es cero justamente la
coordenada x es cero mientras que la
altura es 1 y eso corresponde
seno de pi medios entonces esto que
tenemos aquí vale 1 verdad ahí está lo
tenemos y entonces podríamos escribir
efe pi medios sería 0 verdad y medios
por 0 es cero y luego tenemos y medios
por uno que es pi medios es verdad y
cómo se vería esto serían digamos
solamente un vector que apunta hacia
arriba verdad en medios que es más o
menos 1.7 que es lo que pintamos aquí no
hay componente en x así que tenemos un
vector como este y podríamos imaginarnos
haciendo esto para todas las distintas
entradas y obtendríamos un montón de
vectores verdad entonces si dibujáramos
esto bueno no vamos a estar dibujando
todas las flechas verdad porque eso
simplemente no sería muy claro así que
vamos a trazar todos los puntos que
corresponden a las salidas de cada uno
de estos vectores y lo que voy a hacer
aquí es una pequeña animación vamos a
borrar un poco y aquí tenemos una
animación donde el ángulo te va a ir
entre 0 y 10 así que vamos a escribir
esto así que el valor te empieza en cero
y es así que vamos a ver qué valores o
más bien que vectores obtenemos como
salidas y qué tipo de curva es así que
ahí está todos estos valores son digamos
para partes entre 0 y 10 verdad y
obtenemos esta esta figura como espiral
y podríamos pensar porque es así y es
que tenemos el coseno dt y el seno de t
escalados por el valor t en sí mismo
verdad así que esto nos da una espiral y
lo que significa aquí es que cuando
tenemos de igual a cero empezamos aquí y
cuando tenemos t igual a 10 estaremos en
esta salida verdad y tenemos una
desventaja al dibujar las cosas así
porque no estamos muy seguros de cuáles
son los valores intermedios ya sabes por
ejemplo podríamos adivinar que a lo
mejor el uno va por aquí quizás el dos
va por este otro lado y con suerte esto
digamos estarán igualmente espaciados a
medida que nos movamos en la espiral
pero no tenemos esa información hemos
perdido la información de las entradas
de verdad simplemente tenemos la figura
de la curva sin embargo si queremos
analítica de describir curvas
necesitamos encontrar una función
paramétrica que las describa verdad y en
realidad en este caso no nos importaría
la velocidad a la cual la recorre ahora
solo para mostrarte como esto podría
cambiar vamos a animar la misma cosa
pero vamos a tener otra función que
dibuja la misma curva entonces empieza
aquí realmente rápido y luego desacelera
verdad si se va más lento a medida que
avanzamos así que esta función no es
igual a tevez es coseno dt de veces seno
de t que era la que originalmente había
escrito de hecho en este nuevo caso pues
empezó bastante rápido verdad por
ejemplo podríamos pensar que el primero
está lejos luego el segundo estará mucho
más lejos y luego el tercero pero a
medida que nos vamos acercando al final
cuando te vale 10 empezará a ir muy
lento y entonces aquí estará el 7 aquí
está el 8 y de hecho es hasta difícil
imaginar o hacer un proceso un progreso
a medida que vamos llegando al 10 verdad
así que
podríamos tener dos funciones diferentes
que dibujen la misma curva y la palabra
elegante para decir eso es que estamos
parametrizar verdad así que estas
funciones están parametrizar una curva y
cuando dibujamos digamos esto en el
espacio de salidas obtenemos la curva y
en el próximo vídeo te mostraré cómo
podríamos tener funciones con una
entrada en dos dimensiones y una salida
en tres dimensiones para dibujar
superficies en un espacio de tres
dimensiones